لم يعد المتحرشون الجنسيون الذين يتربصون خلف
شاشات أجهزة الكمبيوتر الخاصة بهم مختبئين
كما يعتقدون أن الشباب يطلقون
مؤسسة غير ربحية تقدم خدمات
لضحايا الاتجار ، وقد أطلقوا مؤخرًا
مبادرة جديدة تعالج الجانب الأقل
مناقشة من مشكلة الاتجار
بالبشر عندما تقوم كل يوم
بخدمة الشباب الذين "  لقد تم
استغلالهم جنسيًا في مرحلة ما ، فتوقف عن
الجلوس لتستريح وتقول مهلاً ما الذي يسبب هذا
لأنه لا حرج مع الأطفال الذين
شعرنا حقًا أننا مدينون
للشباب الذين نعمل معهم للعمل في المنبع
قليلاً والبدء في فعل ما  يمكننا
كمنظمة غير حكومية أن نتعامل مع الاستغلال
الذي كانوا يواجهونه في تعقب الطلب ،
ببساطة ، يقوم الموظف بنشر إعلانات
عبر الإنترنت تعرض الأحداث لممارسة الجنس
على عكس الإعلانات الأخرى الموجودة على مواقع مثل
هذه الخاصة بها ،
وهي عبارة عن أفخاخ ونماذج وافق جميع
البالغين على طرحها من أجل
تنقر على نشر وتنتظر عندما يتصل أحد
المحتالين المحتمل أو يرسل رسالة نصية للرقم الموجود في
متتبع طلب الإعلان يضيف تلقائيًا
الرقم إلى  قاعدة بيانات عامة قابلة للبحث
، يُرسل إلى المتصل أيضًا رسالة نصية
لإعلامه بأن رقمه قد تم
تحديده ومتاح
لرجال إنفاذ القانون الذين يتورطون في
سلوك الطفل هذا ، ويبدأون في مكان ما
إذا فعلت ذلك في المرة الأولى التي أدركت فيها أن
شخصًا ما يشاهده وأنا  سنتحمل
المسؤولية عن هذا الأمر ، وتولي سلطات
إنفاذ القانون اهتمامًا
لهذا النوع من الرسائل التي نعتقد أنها
ستثقف الرجال لتغيير مسارهم
بسرعة حقيقية في الأشهر الأربعة التي
تم فيها تشغيل أداة تعقب الطلب ، فقد
سجل 12000 رقم فريد
يفعله النظام  لها حدودها ، يمكنها
تحديد أرقام الهواتف ولكن لا يمكنها تحديد من
يجري المكالمات ولا يمكنها فصل
المكالمات المقصودة عن أنماط الخطأ إذا
أراد شخص ما إزالة رقمه من
قائمة المواجهة العامة ، فهناك زر
على الموقع يسمح له بالقيام بذلك
ولكن  الرقم لا يزال في
قاعدة البيانات نفسها يقول ترودو إن الشرطة
مهتمة بشكل أساسي بالأرقام التي
تظهر عدة مرات مثل هذه  من المحتمل
أنه ليس من قبيل الصدفة ، إنه ليس مثاليًا ، لكن العديد من الأشخاص
وتطبيق القانون يرونه
بداية رائعة لمعالجة الطلب ، فقد لا يكون
شيئًا يمكننا استخدامه في
حالة معينة ، لكنني أعتقد أنه من
الجيد المساعدة في دفع التشريعات إلى سن
قوانين أكثر صرامة ضد
يمكن للمشترين أن يساعد في الجمع بين
المناهج التدريبية حول كيفية تتبع
المشترين من خلال النظر في
أنماطهم وعاداتهم ، كما أنه يرسل رسالة واضحة
إلى الحيوانات المفترسة أننا نلاحق
جانب الطلب بنفس الصعوبة التي نتبعها
بعد المستغلين وبعد
العرض  جانب من هذه المشكلة
ولن تكون آمنًا خلف
لوحات المفاتيح تلك التي
سنجدها وسنحاكمك Robyn
Curnow CNN Atlanta